this question said using t results you
don't have a choice the method is
prescribed ok so I have to do that with
this question I will point out to you
that tears ask questions are sort of
much less pain for you then they were
for me because on this now in case you
don't remember cheer results as an
extension one thing right so when you
have a look at the reference sheet let's
scroll it begins with all the tools
stuff this is just your algebra and so
on you can see our this series and
sequences stuff there as well good lord
they give you exact values okay that's
fine let's move on a bit further you can
see here's where all the calculus
opinions and since we are doing it right
now I will also point out but look at
these guys right they're all there even
the derivatives and the chain rule
results are there no excuses okay now i
will again repeat just like I did when I
first introduced this sheet but
especially for a class like you I'm not
expecting that you will be referring to
this because it should be all up here it
is faster if it's up here if you have to
refer to something there's a time
penalty associated with this this sheet
particularly this part of this sheet is
not intended for you okay Zoe says
however as we move on this is the part
that I'm interested in so you can see
here you've got the tea formulas they're
right on the left hand side on wheels
within between okay and they are
situated here underneath the angle some
identities big for why why are they
there
well because where these come from is
from a specific instance instance of one
of these namely which one it's the
double angle for 10 okay so what I'm
going to quickly walk you through before
I just go ahead and solve the question
is remember i said like i don't think
you should necessarily be going here to
remember this it's a nice check it's a
nice safety blanket but where does it
come from okay here's the way people
back in the days before a reference
sheet work through and understood this
and therefore made sure they remember
correctly okay I'll tend to x 10 to it
this is a result you absolutely should
know most people have no trouble
remembering this one after if you used a
little bottle it's 210 x odd 1-10 twit
ok so this result here you can see comes
directly out of here one of the easy
ways to remember that there's a there's
a plus or a minus having q right how do
you remember which one's a plus and a
minus well if you put a minus here and
there was a double angle you just get 0
that's not right okay so that's how you
know your posit in the top they gave on
the bottom okay if I then go ahead and
replace to X with X by half all the
angles there I'm going to write this all
of the angles get hard and there you can
see can you recognize this in connection
to this do you see it there's my there
in my teeth right left hand let t boot
animation to so on the basis of that I
say if 10 x equals this then it is
reasonable to start off visually by
saying well if x were an acute angle I
could construct a right angled triangle
that includes it yes and the ter
relationship connects which two sides
opposite and adjacent right so here's to
t here's 1 minus t squared and there's
only one thing left if you need
you can go right back to Pythagoras but
those people are quite fun to remember
eventually well the last one must be 1
plus T Square another way to remember or
that must be the case is because the
hypotenuse is the longest side of a
right angle triangle right so clearly
you couldn't have 1 minus t squared over
there and 1 plus it meant that would
admit ok so off the base of this
triangle this is the triangle that I
used to draw right next to my exact
value triangles to remember all of these
guys ok you'd read these straight off of
here ok now we're ready to approach this
question when you have a look at this
the first thing you must do is a
straight substitution so if you let t
equal to tear our xr2 ok you must say
that because we're on earth of these
tears come from I'm going to look at
this and say that's 1 over 1 over
whatever clothes right so I'm going to
be taking the reciprocal of this guy
right it looks like I've got three times
1 plus T squared 1 minus t spoon do not
do that just a straight substitution of
one of the cops minus and this is
addressed it was fun so where do I begin
from here what's the obvious first step
to do I could put them together as a
fraction you can see eventually unvetted
I'm aiming towards a quadratic i mean
the the team results themselves are
always leaning towards a quadratic
because those t-squares flying around so
i might as well sort of save myself the
effort and just made the quadratic right
way by multiplying through you see that
going to multiply through by the common
denominator which is why in fact they
gave you this it's in fact to make it
easier for you ok comma delimiter so i'm
going to multiply through by 1 minus t
squared let's just do it all the way
are you happy with that this just needs
a minor amount of tidying up i guess i'm
going to add and then i'll subtract
looking good two by two by two because
there's no reason why not to and at this
point i didn't intend it to them at this
point you're looking you think okay no
one you have no choice do you write this
is a disgusting quadratic you're not
gonna be able to do anything meaningful
with it so I'm going to do a stretch
you're same t is equal to and i will
launch into the quadratic form okay now
i don't think the quadratic formula
something that are too concerned with
you in terms of getting your finances so
i think we can go straight to say minus
b plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus side B right yeah b
squared minus 4ac right so that's going
to be 1 plus 16 that sounds like 17 to
me yep / a 2a which is eight and it
doesn't get any simpler than that so now
what does is tell me ass off the tee
that's as far as you can go with tea but
tea in fact is headed exhale 2 3 i'm
going to bring it back to the actual
question i'm scheming
so from here I'm actually looking to
bother too much with the actual
mechanics of this because I think we're
okay you've got two separate values that
X 1 to 10 of X on who could be that
means you've got to 7000 exon 2 could be
okay so you're going to have 10 of exon
2 equals the first solution or 10 of X
12 equals the second solution right you
can use your calculator find the angle
that will give you X onto they don't
shift down now give another number and
this will be in radians right then what
are you gonna do with those yeah you
actually saw it 4x not for me for exile
too so you're going to multiply both of
those by 2 and these will give you some
solutions okay now there are two things
left to check two things that's Jack ok
firstly I need to make sure I haven't
missed any solutions ok so from this
point you can check fairly easily
knowing that the periodicity of these
two functions is well let's have a kid
this is 1 over cars and this is 10 so
therefore it's going to be a bit messy
but you'd go every PI radians ok because
you get the same copy areas of the plane
you can check each of those sessions
really easily by popping them in if you
stay with the exact values you can
literally do three over cause whenever
10 of whatever and over you'll get five
at the end so just test that is a much
simpler way and try to work out
quadrants this way the other you're
wasting time any detail that was the
first thing you need to check domain
what was the second thing hi hi I need
to test x equals play well done why do I
need to do that
very good my very first line of working
this one here immediately excludes plans
of solution as soon as you're talking in
int and you're kind of stuck right so
you have to test x equals we used to say
x equals 180 because 180 degrees on two
is 19 weeks where 10 is a discontinuity
but of course we're in Radian later okay
from memory i don't believe x equals pi
is a solution but you need to show that
there is i believe this is a three-mile
question the third mark is exclusively
for showing whether this is or is not a
solution and it's a classic being I mean
after you've gone through all this
legwork you're just exhausting like it I
get to the next question and many since
we'll just forget to do it okay and
sacrifice a mark which is very easy to
get just chucking to calculate up I'll
get a value out what is the value by the
way what is three sec pi minus 10 we
could actually work this out you're
gonna wait what'swhat's sec pie what's
caused by close pi is negative one the
reciprocal of negative 1 is negative one
so that's negative 3 what's ten pies ok
so all the needs to say here is that is
not equal to five therefore x equals pi
is not a solution and having excluded it
i just returned back to my original okay